We've spoken in the past to psychiatry tree
professor, Dr. John Gardner on the show about
his concerns regarding Donald Trump's mental
state.
And as I mentioned to you before, there is
another psychiatrist, dr bandy Lee, who is
increasingly talking about, um, what appears
to be something very wrong with the president
of the United States.
Dr bandy Lee is a forensic psychiatrist at
Yale's school of medicine and also president
of the world mental health coalition.
And Dr. Lee has written a piece after Donald
Trump's assassination of Iranian leader Kaseem
Solemani that we should be looking at very
closely because it's so disturbing.
And immediately, you know, the, the, the military
explanation, the strategic explanations of
the, uh, Solemani assassination made no sense.
And many of us went to Trump, wants to distract
from impeachment, from, wants to help himself
get reelected in 2020 believes that assassinating
Kaseem Solemani may help them achieve that
goal.
But there's another angle to this and what
dr bandy Lee says is that narcissistic madman
is essentially what explains what we are seeing
from Donald Trump here.
Check this out from a dr Lee's piece.
So what is happening with the president?
It is what my esteemed colleague and former
director of a division at the national Institute
of mental health, dr John Zinner, has warned
about narcissistic rage.
He joined me in leading the petition to Congress
for he believed too that while impeachment
was important, Donald Trump had the real potential
to become even more evermore dangerous as
his condition progressed as a threat to the
safety of our nation, short of his sole command
over nuclear weapons.
There were many other dangerous he can pose
by the use, fueled by rage of his assumed
absolute executive authority and by the loyalists
who serve him.
And as Dr. Lee goes on to explain this further,
it is a spitting image of Donald Trump.
Particularly analyzed in the context of the
Solemani assassination.
Check this out.
Quote, anyone who has seen attacks of narcissistic
rage knows it can be brutal and destructive.
The afflicted, outraged at the deprivation
of the adulation to which one feels entitled,
becomes blind to other concerns such as the
safety of others or the self upon collapse
of one's grandiose image, which required adoration
to buttress.
One is no longer capable of repressing the
painful feelings of inferiority and inadequacy
that resurface.
This experience is more menacing than any
existential threat could be.
Access to weapons or war.
Making power in such a state is extremely
dangerous for they become highly attractive
as a means of restoration.
Mistakes of the past such as aggression in
the middle East are likely to repeat in more
serious form rather than be avoided.
This is Donald Trump period.
And the things that are, uh, uh, the thing
that's starting to get awkward is that we
know there are people in Donald Trump's cabinet
and in the Senate that know that this is true.
They are sort of in this Russian roulette.
Do you fire the gun and maybe get another
conservative?
Judge confirmed while Donald Trump is acting
wacky or does Trump pull the trigger in a
serious way up to and including even the topic
of nuclear war seemed to be a possibility,
uh, earlier this week, although not in a serious
manner.
This is a good time to mention there are a
ton of people who are so desensitized to the
way that Donald Trump typically behaves.
I talked about this yesterday.
They saw Donald Trump's speech on Iran two
days ago, and because Trump merely lied and
stuck to the prompter instead of doing his
usual antics, a lot of people are saying,
wow, what a presidential speech by Donald
Trump.
He seems completely fine.
Donald Trump giving one speech that's not
completely unhinged, should not make us forget
all of the things he's done and said, which
gets us back to Republicans.
Many Republicans, the ones that know the degree
of absurdity, that is Donald Trump.
Once Donald Trump has gone the ones whose
careers outlived Trump's presidency, they're
immediately going to either pretend that Trump
never happened or that they never really liked
Trump.
They weren't really with them to begin with.
Others will blame things that happened under
Trump's watch, either on Obama or on whoever
follows Donald Trump.
If the person who follows Donald Trump is
a Democrat, Republicans have many reasons
to keep Donald Trump in office right now.
Some are getting their stuff done while Donald
Trump goes crazy.
Others are themselves compromised because
in the end, when the rubber meets the road,
you have a completely unhinged ignorant president
who assassinates an Iranian leader without
the congressional authorization he claimed
president's need and they rally around him
other than Mike Lee and start their defenses
with, well, this guy was no angel.
Soleimani was a bad guy.
There's lots of bad guys out there.
They are part of the problem every time they
run interference for Trump with those talking
points because they, uh, that is a completely
different discussion.
Who's bad is a very different discussion than
what Donald Trump did without congressional
authorization to Kaseem Soleimani.
And particularly when you consider the question
of why he did it, not because of any actual
national security imperative.
We've seen the razor thin, bogus justification
from the administration, but to take attention
away from impeachment and also because he
believes on some level that it will help bolster
his shot at reelection in November of 2020
we can't let it continue to make sure you're
following us on Instagram for more on this
and other stories from today's show.
Cat David packing
break back after the